[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute gibt es wieder ein grundrezept
einen basic rezept ich mache meine motiv
torten und auch so meine trocken immer
ganz gerne mit einem mandelöl zeigt da
ist zum einen super saftig sehr
aromatisch oder man kann ihn wirklich
wunderbar abwandeln heute gibt es das
basic rezept ich mache einmal die
standard-variante und dann bekomme ich
immer wieder fragen und ihr fragt immer
wieder kann man nicht auch den zucker
reduzieren oder zucker austauschprojekte
benutzen das heißt ich zeige euch zuerst
einmal das basic rezept dann machen wir
die hälfte des zuckers rein und dann
nehmen wir ein zucker austausch produkt
und dann seht ihr auch einfach den
unterschied
ich zeige euch mal die zutaten für den
teig verwende ich drei eier dessen
zimmer war 150 gramm zucker eine prise
salz etwas vanille extrakt den abrieb
einer unbehandelten zitrone 150 gramm
butter milch 150 gramm sonnenblumenöl
225 gramm mehl einen halt teelöffel
backpulver und 100 gramm mandeln die
eier kommen jetzt in eine rührschüssel
und ihr könnt den teig jetzt entweder
mit der küchenmaschine zubereiten oder
mit dem handrührgerät kommt der zucker
dazu etwas vanille extrakt
und salz und jetzt die zutaten richtig
lange verrühren bis die eier zuckermasse
richtig schön dick und festes
die mandeln die mahlzeit so haben sie
nämlich noch er richtig volles aroma
[Musik]
hier kommen jetzt die zwei flüssigkeiten
dazu und buttermilch ich muss sagen ich
hatte heute keine butter milch da da
habe ich einfach naturjoghurt gemischt
mit etwas mineralwasser und ein spritzer
zitronensaft rein das geht auch das
sorgt dafür dass der teig richtig schön
saftig bleibt jetzt kurz unterrühren und
dann nehme ich eine zitrone
da kann ich die schale mit rezept da
muss man beim kauf darauf achten
ich arbeite hier sie jetzt mit zitrone
ihr könnt aber auch zu entnehmen ihr
könnt auch bis in kakaopulver nehmen
also den teig könnte wirklich super
abwandeln
hier gebe ich sogar noch ein bisschen
immer dazu irgendwann müsst ihr gar
nicht schälen es reicht wenn ihr die
schale und die hatten stellen so ein
bisschen ab schreibt ich entfernen meist
nicht mal die ganze schale und ich hatte
den jetzt gefroren so habe ich immer
irgendwie da frischlinge und gefroren
dass sie sich auch echt super fein
reiben
[Musik]
und da ist einfach nur wichtig
irgendwann zitrone wirklich erst nach
dem aufschlagen dazugeben mit den
flüssigen zutaten am besten damit die
eier zucker maße auch wirklich sehr gut
verrührt werden kann
jetzt kurz einrühren
mehl und backpulver habe ich jetzt
bereits gemischt die werden wir jetzt
dazu gesiebt
und dann kommen hier noch die mandel mit
rein und dann wirklich die zutaten nur
noch kurz ein rühren
steigen sie etwas flüssiger daher
schlage ich den bug ring gerne in etwas
backpapier 1
ich ziehe den teig immer gerne am rand
so ein bisschen hoch damit er noch
gleichmäßiger aufgeht
und jetzt im vorgeheizten backofen
backen und während dieser zeit rühre ich
noch mal den gleichen tag aber mit der
hälfte an zu können
[Musik]
jetzt stelle ich einen teig mit birken
zucker verwirrten zucker ist ein
zuckeraustauschstoff und anscheinend
auch für diabetiker geeignet aber falls
ihr diabetiker seit oder für diabetiker
bagdad informiert euch bitte vorher beim
arzt als spieler jetzt keine gesundheits
themen ansprechen bei becken zucker ist
es auch so der schmeckt ähnlich süß wie
normaler zucker hat aber 40 prozent
weniger kalorien
daher ist er eben auch ganz gut geeignet
und ihr könnt ihn einfach eins zu eins
austauschen
und jetzt mache ich noch eine variante
mit kokos blüten zucker das ist auch im
zuckerersatzstoff der ist schön dunkel
und riecht und schmeckt auch leicht mal
sich man sagt er soll gesünder seien als
normaler zucker wissenschaftliche
studien gibt es leider noch nicht so
viele aber er hat fast genauso viele
kalorien wie normaler zucker man sagt da
war das hat den blutzuckerspiegel nicht
wie weißer zucker in die höhe schießen
lässt und dann wieder abfallen lässt
sondern er wird einfach nicht so sehr
hoch steigen problem als auch aus mit
kokos blüten zucker habe ich echt schon
öfter gebacken
von daher geschmacklich finde ich einen
super man kann ihn wirklich super
ersetzen und mir schmeckt die caramelle
genug auch sehr gut
[Musik]
hier seht ihr jetzt alle ich finde
optisch sticht einer heraus daher ist
der normale also mit normalem zucker
halb so viel zucker hier ist beten
server und hier mehr hier ist chaos
blühten zucker das sieht man an der
farbe und hier ist wirken zucker im
prinzip sind alle böden gleich hoch
außer der mit halb so viel zucker
es liegt einfach daran dass man eben
weniger masse hat um sie mit den eiern
aufzuschlagen
also weniger zucker heißt auch weniger
volumen ich bin jetzt einfach mal
gespannt riechen tun sie alle lecker ich
bin gespannt darauf ich lasse jetzt
einfach das team probieren und die
sollen einfach mal sagen was sie
schmecken und ich werde natürlich auch
probieren
also ich traue mir alle kurz zusammen
und dann probieren wir also ich habe
hier viel kuchen gebacken alles das
gleiche rezept nur habe ich bei einem
normalen zucker drin
bei einem halb so viel zucker wir können
zucker und kokos blutzucker hat er mir
zu ja ok ich hab' kommunion und meine
mama ich hab dich haben gezogen ich habe
die pflicht diese flieger sitzt du noch
gerade ich kann es sein dass ich auch
sehr kleine die eu immer die schule
genommen wurden so kommen wir probiert
frank kommt alle reihe beck kompakt
dann kam eigentlichen problem auch
kuchen übrigens an mir und dann sehr
madame ihr könnt ihr sehen was der zug
aus menschen machen
ich probiere es einfach nein sagt heun
waren wir übrigens von den partnerlook
mit den grünen sei jetzt einfach aber
ich kann die ganze torte ist nein ich
schneide es raus wir ihm ist beurteilen
als zum ersten was am besten schmeckt
die konsistenz die konsistenz trocken
nicht trocken die luft die ich nicht
luftig also okay dann sag mir was am
besten schmeckt
wir wissen ja nicht jedes buch ich weiß
was es war wir merken uns jetzt nur mehr
machen jetzt da rein okay wir machen
jetzt nummer eins ich spreche dass er
zwar okay ist das okay für alle
ich habe meine hände gewaschen ich meine
ich hab den kuchen gebacken
die staubkokons was es geht um sex ist
ein
es geht um den zucker vergleichen
eschweg cocos raus oder kokos oder genau
erheben
aber ich bin der gleiche tag immer dass
der gleiche tag immer die gleiche menge
aber warum sie nebenbei haben
das liegt an den verschiedenen zucker
ich hätte mich auch verbinden soll
was kommt jetzt von dir dass ich warte
ab wie ghostbusters habe sterben hier
etwas unter das stück immer das gleiche
mein gefühl sagt zugleich nicht nicht
beeinflussen aber denken denkt denkt
und jetzt
ich bin fertig
kann es sein dass er gleich allem was er
gegessen hat
speed contest ich fand aber süße jetzt
nimm dir ruhig nimm dir bekommen
ich weiß dass alles erdbeer banane als
auch nicht alles pass auf jetzt um 1
gefallen er bis alle probiert und jetzt
zeigt euch zeigt es auf das was am
besten geschmeckt hat
also wir machen jetzt genau das erste
gas war um 22 34
ok ihr könnt einfach so finger in die
höhe strecken okay was sollte ich am
besten geschmeckt okay 1 2 3 oder 4
ich habe nur zwei hände von drei handy
aufgenommen wird
ich will mir so sicher das ist immer so
dass das was am besten schmeckt wie
wichtig es sei dass wieder zurück ich
habe ich recht ist er mit normalem
zucker ist wie kein zweiter warum ihr 26
schmeckt halt einmal kräftig und das
genau sei auch richtig sagt ich aber
netz 52 der kurz blicken zu können
deshalb automatisch was war es bei dir
die 4
deswegen sehe ich das so auch mit halb
so vielen ich bin zwar ja krass dass wir
zweiter hinzu am besten gemacht habe ich
weiß aber auch warum will er auch zucker
auch günstiger ist
ich weiß auch warum motto ist nämlich
allgemein ganzes du trinkst auch ein
café und ein test
mag schon noch aus meinem leben was auf
glaube was vielleicht 20 millionen
menschen wissen möchten wie wenn sie zb
durch generell weniger süß und wo ich
halt gar nicht also aber was ich sagen
kann
warte weiter richtig trocken
das heißt wenn ihr euren zucker
halbieren wollt könnt ihr das machen
austauschen könnt ihr auch das halt so
eigene geschmackssache
ich fahre jetzt auch alle vier gut aber
ich fand den mit kokos briten sogar echt
cool aromatisch also der war schon und
schön saftig
aber ich finde es echt der hammer als
folge passt dass wir zwei songs habe ich
glaube vor allem wir nichts da der
schule bewusst ist ein unterschied dass
hier möchte naja ich schaue die show
gemacht sein war wie das thema crowd
über eine schulklasse drüber dann merkt
man ganz unruhig werden da können auch
die hälfte des zuckers sparen die
rezepte findet ihr alle auf cds -
blog.de probiert gerne mal aus und wenn
ihr möchtet dass ich andere basic
rezepte ausprobiert hefeteig rührteig
wird dann schreibt sie in die kommentare
dann machen wir hier den test bis zum
nächsten mal
man könnte hier auch die amag meine gebe
er auch gewesen
zucker weg lasst und da einfach sneakers
es ja auch was also war lustig
das ist schon klasse
[Musik]